чи потрібно поліпшенням вузли та фарбування не
100 сумки в Росії це польші зал новий
збаражі не в руки і шинного
політичного режиму хто ще путін
завищувати опри володіти я [ __ ] я на магай
з берега ти контакти та проводить
ідеальність у пивних
а калюжах я потру ну російським фестиваль
кіно ми з дитинства супутник червовий
фестиваль вкотре розпочинається 5 листопада
також за б з піччю фінансову petrenko
фестивалю
збоку польського у влади c1100 suite
культури тут мама і мастю проти тієї ж
з політичної точки зору так до
росією агресором в Україні
артурчик ось і на зад і вниз рушіння
у наших вино сина від добра в польщі
сприймає відпали зараз прямо і росію
путінську росію я коза грози свої
біскотті і своєї безпеки так само
пофіг хоч вона нібито з середньої
завантажу сама туманну хідечу
україна була закладена державою в
почім з осягаємо і потім ще
буваєте в середині Росії
сама тому мотиву йому росіян на вихідних
за росію тополі таку владимира путіна
для пізніше було чесно значення мати люди
на дзвіницю ми ж їм і свобод тому я
і мої колеги завжди зроблю цей мод
їх росіян та кіпру вниз демократичну
росію зібрався було вдома катати